الفكر الحركي همم قدم الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في وقت مبكر جدا يعني حتى يمكننا
ان نقول ان اول تنظيم للاخوان المسلمين في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه كان عام
1937 للميلاد يعني بعد انشاء جماعه
الاخوان في مصر همم تسع سنوات تقريبا همم
طبعا حسن البنا عندما كان ياتي الى موسم
الحج همم يعني عامل على انشاء هذا التنظيم
همم طبعا بشكل غير معلن همم حاول جنس نبض
همم
همم المملكه العربيه السعوديه من خلال
طرحها على الملك عبد العزيز رحمه الله همم
فكره انشاء فرعون ورد عليه الملك عبد
العزيز غفر الله له برد حاسم في هذا
الموضوع ااه ثم ااه يعني توالى النشاط هذه
الجماعات لكن لم يكن لها بريق لدى
المثقفين ولد النخب همم وذلك همم ان ال-
ال- الوهج في ذلك الوقت كان همم التيارات
القوميه واليساريه وهمم شيوعي والبعث
والناصر والقومي وما الى ذلك فهذا الوجه
كان مستمر في الخمسينات اربعنات الخمسينات
الستينات حتى عامه 1967 وهو مرحله انكسار
هذا المد فاستغل الحركيون الاسلام
الامويون همم في طبعا في العالم كله ومن
بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه هذا الامر
وب ببناء القواعد الشعبيه لهم